there's a ninth in Westbrook the I'd
like double-team him in the backcourt
Paul turns it over with the steal
[Music]
a cataclysmic collapse by okay see now
by them trying to go the length of the
floor give the coaching staff at
Philadelphia credit they double-teamed
in the background and they Rin throwed
her over to the side in that double-team
but Jimmy Butler pumps from the other
side watch to the left to your screen
now watch
there he comes left his man came down
and how about that finish and I think
Paul George has to get a touch at some
point and he does the three-ball quickly
George Paul on the job incredible now
let me tell you what what a game he has
played here in the second half now watch
him come off that's here he comes off
the screen and then he goes up right
away you say well what happened Butler
was a half a step back why because the
screen is a big screen by Adams now you
still have to make the shot that was an
incredibly great shot watch
Paul George now with 30 points
remember we I was worried about him
early on you know in the second half